ils sont finalement 8 à passer le
barrage de la primaire à droite nathalie
kosciusko morizet surtout hervé mariton
créé la surprise en obtenant leur
parrainage l'appel d'alain juppé et de
certains noms de personnalités ont
permis de libérer par exemple des élus
qui hésitaient préférez quoi schengen
non mais là des qualités
mais vous savez pas lesquelles
une des femmes du commando qui voulait
frapper la capitale avec une voiture
piégée a été mise en examen hier soir et
écroués dans ce contexte nicolas sarkozy
présente des mesures choc pour lutter
contre le terrorisme partout france est
suspecté d'être lié au terrorisme doit
faire l'objet d'un placement préventif
dans un centre de rétention fermée par
les préfets ont la possibilité de les
mettre en résidence surveillée je suis
tout à fait favorable ce qu elle aille
plus loin à ce moment les mettre dans
les centres de rétention dont vous avez
une condition important ce beau jeu les
dires château et à une condition c'est
que nous respectons un principe
fondamental c'est que l'autorité
judiciaire en france est garante des
libertés publiques il se trompe sur la
forme en faisant croire aux français et
de manière terrible qu avec lui ou fond
il n'y aurait plus de temps en temps il
part je vois des gens beaucoup de gens
un sincère dans la vie politique qui
défendent quelque chose puis qu'ils
défendent exactement la verse en
fonction de leur intérêt électoral pour
dîner avec emmanuel macron la veille
certains sympathisants ont déboursé
jusqu'à 7500 euros le plafond pour aider
financièrement un mouvement politique
moi je veux que nos idées puissent
avancer
je n'ai pas la chance d'avoir des
subventions publiques donc je veux le
faire de manière très régulière très
transparente primaire de gauche je
n'irai jamais par loyauté parce que si
c'est un autre élu je respecterais pas
je ferai pas campagne pour hollande je
ne ferai pas campagne pour vale etc si
nous ne faisons pas nous sommes
aujourd'hui à peu près certain d'une
élimination programmées comme une sorte
de réédition du 21 avril 2002 mais
madame avant de venir sur l'actualité
que vous avez l'air de aussi mal
connaître que le reste mais je vais vous
dire une chose il ya des foyers non
madame
vous avez ce côté avec les médias c'est
assez terrible avait une sorte d'
agressivité vis-à-vis des médias médias
ça reste pas ma contre pouvoir
aujourd'hui un
mettre la pression sur alstom objectif
d'une réunion interministérielle ce
matin à l'elysée le groupe menace de
fermer son site de belfort 400 emplois
sont menacés l'état ne remplit pas son
rôle quand il n'arrive pas être bien
informés alors même qu'il détient n'est
pas important dans une entreprise c'est
par manque de dialogue c'est un défaut
d'autorité de la part du chef de l'état
parc le premier ministre découvre ce
week-end la situation d' alstom alors
que l'état est actionnaire on se demande
mais que fait ce gouvernement qu'a fait
monsieur macro la décision prise par le
groupe alstom il ya quelques jours est
une décision soudaine brutale et
inattendue
nul ne méconnaît les difficultés du
groupe alstom et surtout de la filière
ferroviaire qui est en surcapacité on le
sait
mais on n'a pas le même caractère on n'a
pas les mêmes on n'a pas les mêmes
exigences personnelles alors que
président de la république nous a fixé
un objectif
celui de faire en sorte qu'à belfort des
activités ferroviaires d'alstom soit
maintenu et j'ai donné cette direction
nous mobiliser pour qu'il y ait plus de
commandes qu'ils soient apportées et
pour que cette entreprise là puissent
garder ses sites ce que j'ai fait pour
alstom à l'étranger alstom doit le faire
aussi pour la france mais nous devons
apporter des commandes par trois
dossiers qui peuvent se concrétiser
rapidement le premier une négociation
directe entre la sncf et alstom sur un
train qui est exploité par la sncf qui
fait paris turin milan milan aujourd'hui
ils ne se sont pas mis d'accord gd
invite à se mettre d'accord je fais tout
pour sauver le site de belfort un plan
d'urgence c'est ce que c'est ce que
tente de faire françois hollande en
étant marchands d'illusions parce qu'en
vérité les coûts de production sont
élevés les commandes publiques sont
insuffisantes c'est tout un plan
stratégique à refaire regarde pas de
stratégie industrielle depuis tant
d'années pourquoi il ya une surcapacité
de production à alstom aujourd'hui qui
est réel mais c'est parce que depuis des
années la france a abandonné le fret
ferroviaire
c'est quand même assez incroyable qu'on
dise pas des choses aussi simplement que
ça quand on est actionnaire principal
d'alstom on ne peut pas feindre de
découvrir bon qu'on va faire mais aussi
demain soir et ce projet est fixé
l'objectif
l'objectif c'est d'assurer la pérennité
du site de belfort alstom pour les
prochaines années pas simplement pour
les deux ans qui viennent non pour les
prochaines années mais dans le même
temps
coup de tonnerre à belfort les salariés
d'alstom reçoivent ce mail de la
direction sans équivoque malgré les
efforts de tous il apparaît aujourd'hui
impossible d'assurer un avenir pérenne
pour les activités du site de belfort
règlement la direction d'aston pas
vraiment de la même oreille que vous ils
sont 100 déterminé à fermer le site de
belfort est ce que c'est un bras de fer
avec le gouvernement en tout cas il peut
pas y avoir deux bras de fer puisque ce
site restera sera pérennisée et j'ai le
sentiment qu'un certain nombre des
déclarations qui ont été faites ce matin
ne sont plus à l'ordre du jour le
communiqué qui avait été envoyé et à
communiquer anciens docks c'est une
erreur de communication
des discussions sont engagées avec le
gouvernement et rien n'est définitif la
situation peut évoluer car voici l'une
des lettres adressées au président de la
république signé par des élus de la
région et datée de mars 2007 un courrier
qui tire la sonnette d'alarmé sur une
possible fermeture de site à cause d'un
manque de commandes ou temps chacun
avait parfaitement conscience des
difficultés que pouvait rencontrer
alstom sur la question de la production
de locomotives en france la décision de
monsieur alain vidalies secrétaire
d'état chargé des transports de
renouveler le parc de tnt via un appel
d'offres et non par extension des
contrats créés cadre ces décisions a
considérablement fragilisé les sites de
production d'alstom transport et ses
milliers d'emplois et précis la
fermeture du site de belfort aucune
information n'avait été mise à
l'information du gouvernement sur cette
fermeture j'entendais hier arnaud
montebourg dire l'état n'a pas fait ce
qu'ils devaient faire mais l'état n'est
pas là en situation de responsabilité ce
n'est pas une annonce de l'état les
acheteurs publics doivent apprendre à
être des patriotes et c'est la
responsabilité des dirigeants de l'état
que de leur apprendre ou de l'échangé
lorsqu'il n'en sont pas capables marque
quand on est actionnaire on anticipe les
choses on les voit venir ça ce pas été
improvisée ça fait un moment qu'on en
parle donc le gouvernement l'a a manqué
de pertinence car j'ai passé une
commande de 3 milliards 8,3 milliards
800 millions à un milliard huit pour un
rer voilà le syndicat des transports
qu'ils résident président de région 240
tram 3 milliards 8 de commande pour un
rer nouvelle génération qui devra être
évidement là vitrine bon il est un sport
il le fabriquer eh bien il ya un appel
d'offres qui est en cours qui passait
par la sncf c'est la sncf qui s'occupe
du rer e et du rer des marques sur ce
contrat c'est la région ile de france
qui aura le dernier mot mais cette piste
est plutôt incertaine car c'est un
groupe ferroviaire espagnol qui serait
le mieux placé le conseil municipal a
voté à l'unanimité une motion demandant
le maintien d'alstom sur son site
historique de belfort alstom il prévoit
de transférer la production d'alsace
ils ont payé 12 milliards les américains
et sur les 12 milliards il ya eu 4
milliards 800 millions pour
l'augmentation des dividendes des
actionnaires d'alstom et du rachat
d'actions ni de poursuites en justice
alstom sa emblématique du constat
d'échec de toutes les politiques
libérales qui ont été menées par des
gouvernements de droite comme de gauche
y compris quand arnaud montebourg y
était d'ailleurs jean-claude mail vous
sont assez remontés contre françois
hollande oui bouillotte quoi franchement
il ya de quoi écouter quand on sait le
président l'a public qui sait lui
premier responsable c'est pas le premier
ministre les ministres le priant un
public dans notre constitution qui est
le premier responsable et c'est lui qui
s'est montré très raide sur la loi
travail par cette nomination elle est là
pour dire c'est pas un baroud d'honneur
le baroud d'honneur ça voudrait dire
quoi ce héros mobilise aujourd'hui
apprendront à la maison n'en parle plus
non on va continuer à traiter le dossier
je vous le dis on va agir à tous les
niveaux possibles voilà on se prive
d'une centrale comme fessenheim il y
aura des problèmes de d'énergie et ça
peut créer de l'emploi dans l'industrie
des bougies peut-être mais c'est ça la
réalité d'un prêt propos clairement
climato-sceptiques l'ancien président a
des doutes sur l' influence de l'homme
dans le réchauffement climatique les
phénomènes de ce genre la planète on a
connu dit il ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
ne faut pas s'en occuper l'homme n'est
pas le seul responsable comment nicolas
sarkozy peut-il me le savoir que toute
la communauté scientifique qui
aujourd'hui est d'accord
elles portent une lourde part de
responsabilité dans la production
végétale et donc dans le réchauffement
climatique levier c'est bien une réalité
parfois je me souviens de nicolas
sarkozy au grenelle de l'environnement
disant que désormais plus aucune grande
politique publique ne pouvait se faire
sans intégrer la question du changement
climatique par le déclin de la
biodiversité la santé environnementale
tel est l'ordre des priorités que j'ai
fixé ce n'est pas une question de
confort et je veux le dire aux français
c'est une question de survie je ne crois
pas qu'il faille renier ses convictions
pour pouvoir conquérir des électeurs
donc oui il faut protéger la planète oui
il faut lutter contre les dérèglements
climatiques
non l'homme n'est pas le seul
responsable du dérèglement climatique
c'est un petit message d'erreur je passe
à ce qu'ils peuvent dire que l'homme n'a
aucune responsabilité dans le
réchauffement climatique je crois que
c'est une grave erreur que de dire ça et
il faut se préoccuper de toute urgence
du grand défi qui est lié au défi
environnemental la démographie c'est
votre nouveau défi voir défilé de
politiques au salon de la coiffure hier
à paris après la visite classique
d'alain juppé bruno le maire s'est
improvisé coiffeurs aux stands les sages
brésilien monsieur macron s'est fait
raser et vous vous coiffer alors c'est
ça oui
moi je préfère avoir
le pen entre les mains envoyé pour
diriger les opérations
trois jours qui prépare la vente mais
moi il en avait marre ce que disait ce
que disait alors si la campagne
présidentielle c'est ça tremblay se
battre quand même ça va être très très
longtemps
la
police était prévenue il paraît que ce
matin vous en fais pas on n'en fait pas
un petit peu pro en communication
alors merci de ce wagon
je viens de la primaire le 27 novembre
et puis après un rendez vous en mai
vernaton garde à toi aussi tu as du mal
à vous servir pour la présidentielle et
qui sait quand on voit ce que coûte un
coiffeur présidentielle vous savez je me
dis que c'est peut-être bien savoir ce
qu'on fait soi même un par christiane
taubira fait la une de libé ce matin
elle sort de son silence dans une longue
interview l'ancien ministre de la
justice exprime sa crainte de voir
disparaître la gauche et pour un bon
moment par si hollande est candidat à la
primaire je le soutiendrai s'il ne l'est
pas je me lancerai si on dit que c'est
vous qui avez qui avait dit ça ou alors
c'est intéressant
oui ça lui d'expliquer mis la puce à un
président de la république a passé son
quinquennat à éliminer tous ceux qui
pensaient pas comme lui et maintenant
ils découvrent qu'il est en culottes
courtes à mon âge je vais me lancer
c'est insensé je n'ai pas dit ça je le
dis clairement là ce n'est pas dit et si
cette personne confirme que je l' ai dit
je savais bien mangé
ça y est je suis candidat de la primaire
de la droite et du centre j'étais en
train de réfléchir à tout ce qui est en
train de vous écrire mais puis-je me
suis dit que j'allais plutôt vous le
bien directement pour la gauche peut
mourir
mais moi comme vous je veux qu'elles
vivent
et je vous le dis simplement
peut-on se permettre dans les prochaines
semaines dans les prochains mois devant
les français dans la situation que nous
connaissons avec des risques que je
viens d'évoquer le luxe de la division
précis à ceux qui m'ont pas rennais
n'est pas soutenue merci à ceux qui
m'ont soutenu et pas parrainer bref
merci ceux qui m'ont porté bon se
convainquent pour les parrainages et
puis merci
merci à jacques séguéla je serai sarkozy
je voterai pour elle